just had a minute to look at the ho
title it's a fairly long title so uh so
let me just spend the first maybe you
know minute to just you know say what I
mean by this title so I want to look at
maximizing gains from trade and
two-sided markets and in the literature
there are essentially two lines of work
okay two types of guarantees the first
type I consider them as asymptotic
efficient mechanisms in the sense that
these mechanism would say look at the
realize you know input if the input
satisfies some nice conditions such as
large market condition the performance
is very good and that if the size of the
market grows the performance converges
to optimal okay so that's what I call
isn't totally efficient mechanisms the
issue is of course what if this large
market condition does not hold and
there's no guarantee whatsoever there
that's the first type of guarantee in
the literature the second type is a very
traditional computer science you know
worst-case guaranteed as it says you
know no matter what inputs are you know
I'll get some fraction of the
performance but the issue here is ball
maybe your inputs actually very nice
it's very easy maybe actually satisfies
the large market condition and you're
being very pessimistic I only getting a
constant fraction without hitting you
know maybe even the optimal okay so in
this time I'm going to present one
mechanism actually gives you those kind
of guarantees and to the best of my
knowledge that's the first
okay so uh so say for this audience I
don't need to motivate they're like you
know why sorry mark is a very important
problem so let me just you know quickly
go over the basics so the very basic
setting is by Auto Trader
you have one item to sell there's one
seller there's one buyer and the seller
has some private costs for parting with
the item which is draw from distribution
there's one Speier who has some private
value for getting the item also draw
from a distribution and so the goal for
this talk is I want to find a mechanism
that maximize efficiency so in this
particular case you should use an
allocation that you know trays whenever
the buyers value is hard and the cost
all right oh so more formally I would
like a mechanism that has the following
conditions I wanted to be IR I see
budget balance meaning that the
mechanism does not lose money by running
and also I want to use this efficient
trade allocation alright that's the
basic case and since we're trying to
maximize efficiency the natural thing to
do is well let's try to run VCG and see
what happens in this case okay if you
run BCG R so we see the tray happens and
the buyer is gonna pay nine dollars
because that's the critical value
whenever the buyer of course higher than
nitrate happens and similarly the seller
needs to be compensated by R by ten
dollars because if the seller reports
anything less than ten the tray happens
okay
so you can wrong BCG but there's a
deficit of one
so miss did you maximize the efficiency
but snot budget balance okay and turns
out no mechanism ok satisfy all these
conditions there's a quite a subtler
resolve Amar's in ourselves why they
show that even in bilateral trade you
cannot have a single mechanism that is
interim I are patient I see weekly
budget balance and use this efficient
trade allocation a very strong negative
result and there has been a lot of we're
trying to sort of circumvent this
negative result and the approach is
let's try to approximate efficiency
while maintaining the other properties
so now I can be a bit more specific
about these two types of guarantees that
exist in the literature ok so the first
one I call to expose asymptotic
efficient mechanisms by expose I mean
that the guarantees on every realization
of the Ty profile okay so once you have
draw the Ty profile from the
distribution this mechanism will look at
the profile and see if it's satisfied
this large market condition if it
satisfies it gives you good guarantee in
fact you know asymptotically efficient
if it does not satisfy and then you know
there's no guarantee at all in
particular the tree reduction by McAfee
is one of satisfied this type of
guarantee and I'll explain that
mechanism
the second type of guarantee is this
worst-case guarantee here I called
ex-ante worst case approximation
guarantee meaning that I want a
mechanism such that in expectation of
the realization of the types its
performance is within some fraction of
the optimal expected performance so a
priori it's not clear you know these are
just incomparable guarantees right and
the way I would like to think about
these two guarantees or so the first
basically saying like I will have a very
optimistic mechanism that works
extremely well if the inputs easy the
second one is the more pessimistic type
of guarantee that says I'll have a
mechanism that just works reasonably
well on average okay but maybe it's not
doing so well even the inputs easy and
okay so the plan is I will show you a
mechanism of each that says for each
type of guarantee and also I'll prove to
you that you know these mechanism they
do not satisfy the other type of
guarantee and I'll show you how you can
actually come up with a new one they
actually sell
okay so before I describe this mechanism
so there's one more thing I want to talk
about so we're gonna be we want to
approximate efficiencies that there are
two different ways to measure efficiency
one is just a traditional welfare
concept the other one is called a gain
some trade and if I can just think about
the incident rate as how much more
welfare you get by running the mechanism
so in this case was the tray happens the
welfare goes from nine to ten so the
gains from traced one so if you want to
maximize welfare it's just the same as
maximize gains from trade but now we're
talking about approximation the two
concepts are actually quite different if
you approximate the welfare it's very
different from approximating in some
tree it's just look at this example if I
don't trade at all it's a good
approximation for welfare but it gives
you zero okay so and the goal for this
tall guys I want to approximate you some
tree okay it's a harder task but that's
what we want to know if you're happy was
approximating welfare there's a lot of
nice results works in quite general
settings but
all right so next I want to introduce
you know these two mechanisms each was a
different type of guarantee okay all
right so I'm gonna be talking about
mechanisms that use a mark large marquee
assumption so clearly I cannot be just
talking about burrata tray because you
only have two agents so you have to have
at least a setting where you know that
the size of the problem can grow okay so
I'm gonna consider the first ones call
the double action so you have n buyers
and sellers H seller has one item the
goods are homogeneous okay there's sink
type items each seller has a private
cost for the item draw independently
from our own distribution every buyer
has a private value when I say double
auction what I mean is every bargain
tray was ever sell
and here is the true reduction mechanism
by McAfee these what you do is the
following
you take the profile okay you sort them
you sort the buyers bids are in
descending order you sort the sellers
bits in ascending order
now you decide queue which is efficient
resize okay
the number of pairs you would tray in
BCG say okay in this case qb3 right and
then what you do is you only tray the
top Q minus one pairs you only trade
these two pairs and that use the third
pair to set the prices the winning
buyers will pay PQ which is sixty
sellers were seve 45 okay so that's the
true reduction mechanism very
straightforward mechanism and the
guarantee that McAfee provided was that
the mechanism is expose IR expose IC
expose budget balance and also gives you
one ones 1 over Q fraction of the
realized gains from trade so what I say
realize meaning that for you know we
suspected this particular type profile
alright I'm a dark room it's very
straightforward
right so budget balances because this is
also a you know possible efficient
repair so the buyer value is higher than
the solid cost and since I'm Joanie
dropping the worse pair I only lose 1
over Q Q goes to infinity I clearly have
something that's almost optimal the
issue is well I mean there's no
guarantee if Q is 1 right
this is something that does not give you
a worst-case guarantee all right so next
let me show you a mechanism that gives
you some worst-case guarantee okay and I
want to first even look at the spot at
attracting it's not going to understand
you mean for Q it's finite yes not
getting to what but if you grow the size
of the market a converges to 1 that's
what I mean by some Tahlia fishes why
does Q converge to 1 so sorry 1 minus 1
or Q converges to 1 if I grow the size
it's not necessary go with the market so
the size of market is Q so that's how
I'm finding it
the efficient tray size Q that grows and
of course if you make some assumptions
on the distribution that you can say
when the size of you know grossed and
you also curves
okay so let me give you a mechanism that
gives you worst case our guarantee about
a trait so if you want to compare to the
first best gain some trait that's just
the highest gain to ensure you can get
are forgetting all the constraints like
Ric you know budget balance that's the
first basket entry if you want to
compare to that we only have conditional
results meaning that you have to make
assumptions on the distributions okay
for example we can get factor two
approximation if the buyers medium value
is higher than the medium of solid cost
or you know some tail condition on one
of the agents distribution even to now
we don't have a worst case guarantee
compared to the first pass without
making assumptions on this room so uh so
what people did is uh and find myself
okay so uh you relax the benchmark so
instead of looking at the first pass
let's look at the second pass
second best is the high schemes ensure
you can get using a mechanism that's I
Ric and budget balance alright so that's
the second best benchmark
and you know turns out if you want the
optimal second best is something quite
complex even a ballot a tray because a
double-action is something it's a
monster so you don't want to look at
that so what we did is we look at an
approximation to the second-best so this
is a result with my student and postdoc
we show that you can have a quite simple
mechanism that gives a half of the
second pass gains from trade let me show
you the mechanisms quite straightforward
so you just run them you run one of the
following two mechanisms first why I
cost seller offering so what you do is
the seller also take a leave a price and
the tray happens whenever buyer accepts
that price okay and how does the seller
decide the price the seller looks at his
cost and the buyers value distribution
figure out figure out a price that
maximize are her expected utility and
you can do the buyer offering which is
just a symmetric version of the seller
offering mechanism so randomly pick one
of the two so this gives you a factor
two approximation tree case
okay and you know that you can
generalize the mechanism to sonars where
you have multiple agents it works for
double action it also works for a more
general case which we call the matching
market case so the difference is now you
have a bipartite graph that specifies
who can trade with home okay and you
know the general selling the Meccans
core random virtual for maximizing
mechanism so I explained why we gave the
mechanism this name so again you do you
pick one of the two following mechanisms
randomly so the first one you you can
think about this mechanism as you're
finding an allocation that maximizes the
sellers Toto over to surplus so let me
explain what it means is you have a
bipartite graph right so that specifies
who can trace whom now for every edge in
the bipartite graph I'm gonna assign a
weight okay what is this weight so for
an edge between fire is solid J I'm
gonna assign this weight here I have
buyers virtual value function so if
you're familiar with auction fear it is
exactly meyerson's virtual value for
this buyer R with respect to mr.
distribution
- the seller cost okay so that's a way
on that edge okay your sign all these
are weights two edges find a maximum
matching that's the allocation okay it's
not hard to see it's a monotone
allocation and fat you know if you
charge the critical values you can proof
is also budget balance alright so I
won't go to that proof but one thing
that might be a but might not be so
clear is why is this the same as the
seller offering mechanism I was talking
about earlier in the bilateral trade
case so there I'm not talking about
anything about virtual values and so on
so so here's why okay so if you only
have one pair in the market one buyer
one seller now yours your to sell you
want to offer a price okay so what is
the allocation you should use
so a little thought reviews that you
should Trey was the buyer whenever the
buyers virtue value is higher than your
cost right okay so that's the allocation
the seller offering mechanism and that
turns out to be exactly the same as here
here you would tray again as whenever
the buyers verge value is higher than
solid cost okay so the two mechanism
have the same allocation and you know
the backup the the prices so they're
equivalent and you do you know the
symmetric version of the seller offering
mechanism randomly chose one of the two
you'll get a factor two approximation in
the even the matching market okay so
this is a mechanism that gives the
worst-case guarantee right so an
expectation over the types you get half
of the optimal okay some trade for turns
out not to be asymptotic efficient yeah
what's the worst case what's the worst
instance
so we don't have a distribution that
shows to is tight so so in that sense I
don't know what's the worst case there
would make any sense
oh yeah right
so I'm relaxing the optimal case my tray
to some benchmark I can use the sum of
the two mechanisms case run tried to
cover that so in particularly will mean
that you can just use one of the two and
you can still get factor two to make
sense so I'm randomized to be cruel to
just you know this is easier to describe
I can do the max of the two yeah yeah I
can do the Maxima to I don't have the
randomness is not necessary one of them
may not work yes if you just used one it
would not work you need to take the
better of the two yeah so there are
instances when you only do one side it's
not gonna work yeah intuition for why
doesn't want to remember the the welfare
proximation mechanisms only used sellers
distribution right they don't that's
that's right but no so first welfare
approximation is very different because
right like why you
I'm not sure I have examples I'm not
sure I I have this do you know some very
easy to communicate out there but you
know right Sao Paulo guava is very
different because no tre very often is a
good solution there and it's a very hard
case for us
okay so this is not asymptotic efficient
and here's one very simple example so
consider very large double auction with
say M buyers and sellers consider M who
you know increase each of this agent has
value cost sample uniformly between zero
one okay so clearly the efficient trade
size will be roughly n minus order root
n or in this case and you know if you
increase n just run tree reduction you
almost get first best right you can get
any fraction within first best okay so
now if your run you know the mechanism I
just described I run the virtue of a
maximizing mechanism it does not
converge to the first pass in fact it
misses at least even a constant fraction
of the second best and the reason is
this because I'm using virtual value to
decide what I'm trading and it's not
really the value a virtual value usually
there's a gap in virtualenv al u so I'm
missing a big trunk of the trades I
won't go into you know details but you
can show that if the bars have valley
between one half and two thirds and the
sellers have caught between one-third
and one-half like no tray will happen
even though it's actually beneficial to
trade okay because the way the mechanism
is set up like no cherry will happen and
that will just make you lose a constant
fraction of the decreasing tree
all right so it's not asymptotic
efficient and so the goal is I want one
mechanism that has post guarantees okay
so it's expose asymptotic efficient with
respect to the first best and ex-ante
approximates the gains from trade
now I'm comparing to the second best no
I think you wouldn't need to be some you
know big constant that's I mean some
constants are comparable to this
fraction because the reason is the tray
here does not happen because you're
looking at a virtual value and that's a
way to maximize utility so you want them
to tray whenever bars value is higher
than the seller cause so basically
that's not a utility maximizing
mechanism so you basically have to have
the Epson all in the IC so large that
they're willing to change from the
utility maximizing mechanism to a
mechanism that always trades so you
would need to absent to be a fairly
there it cannot be something that's a
yeah
so I'll show you one mechanism that are
achieved both one thing I want to point
out is if we're in algorithm design this
is a trivial task if you have an
algorithm you have two hours and one is
asymptotic efficient the other one you
know gives you some worst-case guarantee
now I want an algorithm that gets past
post rolls
that's trivial right take your instance
run those algorithms take the better
result you're done right it's for
algorithms okay
mechanism turns out that's not okay
we have to imagine isms and one system
taught efficient the other one has worst
case guarantee you cannot just simply
run the two mechanisms and take the
better one because it's not gonna be
incentive compatible that's a tricky
part I'll show you one example where
this actually happens okay so you have
to do something more careful
okay so uh just remind everyone that the
big picture so the optimal mechanism are
quite complex hard to design we have
worst-case guarantee we also have
asymptotic optimum mechanisms we're
looking for something that lies are in
the intersection for the rest of the
talk I have ten the rest of talk so I
think I can depth how long do I have 20
[Laughter]
20 is good then okay
I don't even minimizing or maximizing
but that okay okay
so I'll show you a mechanism that gives
you both guarantees for double auctions
and then I'll talk about matching
markets in fact McAfee is tree reduction
was only defined on double-action was
not defined on matching markets so we
have to first come up with a
generalization of that mechanism and now
show you how you how you can get
modified mechanism to get both type of
guarantees okay double auction okay so
here is this very naive or poach I was
talking about okay so let's try to do
this okay so for the reported profile BS
I'm gonna first compute Q the efficient
trade size if Q is at least two I'm
gonna run the trail reduction because
already there you hadn't have some
guarantee right what mine is 1 over Q if
Q is one true duction gives you nothing
in fact reduction would not even do
anything I'm gonna run this random
virtue of her maximizing mechanism okay
all right so let's look at one
particular example so I have let's say
only two buyers to sellers and now if I
run this particular mechanism and say b2
has value 90 98 here will be 2 right so
i ron't row reduction this edge will be
reduced to only the only two pairs are
traded the only two agents are trading
RB 1 and s 1 okay so that's what happens
in this mechanism
now imagine that B to R is 80 instead of
98 okay not only have Q equal to 1 right
just no longer so Q is 1 so I'm not
running a tree reduction I'm jumping to
this step okay I will run this random
virtue of a maximizing mechanism and if
you compute the virtual values for the
buyer and the two buyers you will see
that the only edge that can trade is
actually this edge
the virtual value would be 2 is positive
the virtual value would be 1 is negative
so this is the only edge taken trade so
that means if P 2 reports ATS you
actually can trade that just gives
incentive for the second buyer to lie
because this my location is just know
monotone alright so the main issue here
is when Q is one this solid offering
mechanism is trading a pair that's not
in first base so that creates this
opportunity for buyer to to July
okay so here's what we do to fix fix the
problem so instead of running the whole
random virtue of a maximising mechanism
just we're gonna force the mechanisms
will only offer tray on the first best
edges okay why is that a good idea I
mean the reason is the only way that an
agent can lie and gain is when this
agent can line to cause a switch between
Q equals to two Q equals one okay well
if I'm forcing you know the mechanism to
only try on first pass edges they should
just try to get into the first pass
edges they still try to you know lie and
go to some other possible edge so that's
irrational and you know a true way to do
is like I can run just random offering
on the first pass edge it is IC
mechanism now there is another issue now
it's not clear whether this is a good
approximation the reason being that all
we know is the solid offering edge will
give you a good approximation now your
training on the different edge okay in
fact it's not even clear how often you
would trade you're just running some
random offering mechanism there the
probably that the tray happens depends
on the distribution there's not even
clear how often the tray will happen so
how do we deal with that
so here is a observation that was very
useful for us besides the key
observation that allows us to design the
mechanism okay so we know the seller
offering mechanisms are taking this edge
okay so that means this edge at least
has some positive gaze of trade is
greater than s1 and now if you want
fire1 to get into the first pass the
power one needs to be at least as big SP
- right okay similarly for s1 to get
into this sell offering edge it better
be that US as well as Lord answer okay
so our approaches steal you do random
offering on the first pass edge but now
I'm gonna ask some restriction on the
prices you can use you're only allowed
to use prices between p2 and s2 okay but
just letting you pick a whatever price
that optimize you know the virus sellers
utility you can only pick prices in this
range okay and this turns out to be
enough to guarantee the tray happens
with good probability the reason it's
quite simple because this red edge is
there so B 2 is greater than s1 or in
fact even the virtuality would be 2 is
greater than s1 so far 1 now say bar
one's gonna do offering to this seller
bar what's gonna offer price that's at
least be 2 right because my restriction
offer B to s1 will accept it so make
sure whenever at least the bar when the
buyer is offering o the tray happens on
this - okay so here's the hybrid
mechanism so I first compute efficient
tray size if Q is at least 2 I run the
true reduction I also I'm gonna run the
tray run the random offering mechanism
on the b-1s one pair with probably 1/2
I let the seller offer by say
you know you can offer a price that's
not higher than s2 and also I tell the
seller that you know buyer wants value
as at least b2 it can be to ask okay and
do something similar for the buyer
that's a mechanism and the guarantee
that we can provide is this mekinese
our big ex post budget balance and it
gives you one quarter of the expected
gates from Trey of the second best I'll
explain why this is not one-half and it
gives you also dis I said asymptotic
efficiency guarantee you get one minus 1
or Q because whenever Q is greater than
2 you're running a reduction so you get
the same guarantee as a true reduction
and the reason that we're not getting
1/2 is basically because you're
comparing to this random virtual welfare
maximizing mechanism and so far we can
only show that you are cover one-half of
that always and that's a factor two
approximation so you get 1/4 but this is
probably not tight okay so let me just
quickly talk about matching markets just
remind you a matching market the only
difference is I not have a bipartite
graph that specifies the possible trade
okay so I think I would just spend a few
minutes talking talk about the trade
auction mechanism in the metro market
okay so in double auction
we have convergence to efficiency if the
market grows now how can we define this
large market or you know efficient
resize in matching markets so if you
just simply add you know more trading
pairs into the graph that's not going to
help right imagine you're gonna add a
bunch of isolating edges that's not
gonna help
imagine you have n parallel no edges
that's just n you know bilateral trade
cases the true reduction it's not gonna
do anything to it okay be more careful
about how you define all this efficient
resize when you actually have you know
an arbitrary bipartite graph okay so
here's one way that we view the double
auction and was useful for our of us to
come up with a generalization so the way
we'll think about this is in double
auction every seller can replace every
other seller in a trade you know they're
replaceable right because everyone can
trade was everybody so I'm gonna
basically put sellers or buyers into
equivalence classes based on you know
the number the the set of agents they
can trade with okay so one thing I want
to emphasize here is I'm talking about
equivalence class I'm talking about you
know sellers can be replaceable I'm not
making assumptions on their
distributions this is just some property
about a graph okay I'm not making ideas
sumption on the distribution
okay so so for matching market we
basically want to define say the number
of trading agents of each class will
grow large I say every two agents in the
same class can trade was exactly same
set of agents so that's how I'm gonna
define the equivalence classes here's
one example so if you're in this market
these two buyers are in one equivalence
class because they didn't trade was
exactly the same set of scholars and you
know for origins you can partition them
into four classes okay so now for every
class I can define the number of trades
okay so here in this particular matching
ah this class has traces too okay in
double action use just one class of
sellers one class for buyers so here
every particular equivalence class has
ah this an associated trade number tree
size so if I say market grows large I
mean that the efficient trade size for
every class grows large
and so this is roughly the mechanism so
I take the profile the top are QT minus
one agents will trade and then you know
the window just needs to pay the value
for the top reduce agent and this is the
guarantee that we managed to provide so
basically gonna take the minimum across
all the equivalence classes and you get
1 minus 1 over Q T in particular you
know if every class has tray size at
least two you get at least a two
approximation if there's one class that
has won only one trade then you don't
get any o guarantee that's a true
reduction mechanism so I'm not gonna
talk about the random offering mechanism
the idea is similar you you basically
only do random offering on the first
pass edges but now the difficulty is
you're gonna come up with some prices
right you want to come up with this
restriction on the prices you can use as
in double action ok what's the analog of
this P 2 and s 2 in double action so it
turns out they coincide with VCG prices
for I and J so you can have actually a
very succinct way of describing this you
know upper bound and lower bounds I
won't go into details
so let me just say the main result so we
show that so I'm going to use alpha to
know the minimum value between this 1
minus 1 over Q quantity and the
mechanism is basically what number alpha
is at least 1/2 you run the true
reduction otherwise run this random
offering mechanism again you have the
same guarantee as in double action you
get 1/4 of the second bath in the worst
case and you get this alpha fraction of
the opt and this alpha goes to 1 if the
market size growth I'm doing is 2 so
here you find the first pass matching
I'm now for every edge in that matching
I'm running some random offering yes
only the edges in the first pass I'm
doing a random offering on every edge
and on every edge I'm computing an upper
bound lower bound on the prices you can
use and those prices depend on VCG
prices in some settings
so yeah so one nice thing I want to
point out is you know you get a
mechanism that's also expose Padre
balance expose IR so if you want interim
IR expose party balance or you know the
other way that's quite easy but if
you're going to get as both guarantees
in most cases ah this is actually the
first I know that you give you this in
no proof sketch
okay let me conclude ah this mechanism
is achieves both types of guarantee and
again I would like to think about this
as a mechanism that gives you some
guarantee on the HAR instances and very
good performance on the easier instances
easy to do for algorithms but quite
difficult for mechanism because
incentives and you know I think it's
interesting to try to find more
mechanisms of this sort that can
actually post our best of both worlds
of Alzheimer oh maybe I can go back to
the proof really okay I can say a few
words about the top our log around
so okay so the mechanisms you find the
first best matching on every edge in
that matching I'm gonna do some random
offering mechanism but I'm gonna ask
some restriction on the prices you can
use here's how I'm gonna compute the
restriction okay so for every edge IJ in
the first pass matching I have a s bar
which is the minimum bid for bar I
if buyer I lowered if FR i has anything
higher than s bar i will still be in the
first pass
even if j is not there so that's the
threshold bit for buyer i to get into
the first pass if j is not there okay so
this is vc g price for i if j is not
there let's think about what this means
in the double auction case okay in the
top offering case you have buyer one and
solid one matching okay so now I'm gonna
compute s Bar okay so that will be the
minimum value for bar I want to get in
the first best when s1 is not there okay
so that's as to exactly be hired as two
to get in there V Bar is the maximum bit
for solid J such that if J reports
anything lower than J will make it to
the first pass even 5s not there okay in
double action case this will be B 2 so
that's how we define the upper lower
bound on the prices you can use and then
just like take for every edge compute
these two quantities run the random
offering in this range
unfortunate I don't I won't be able to
say more about why these are good things
so basically the argument in the end is
you know you're gonna cover you try to
use the first best matching to cover the
solid offering mechanism so the right
edges are the ones in the cellar
offering mechanism the green ones are
are in the first pass and you have a
bunch of a possible you know are
alternating cycles and pass and you can
show basically a large trunk of them are
impossible these are impossible because
you're looking at first pass for example
this one is impossible because if the
seller offering can match these three
edges first pass should take these three
edges as well okay so there are things
you can just rule by definition these
are the only two cases need to deal with
I do have even past when both endpoints
are buyers or you have some all pass
okay and turns out this these two you
can cover using the random offering
mechanism because the upper and lower
bounds make sure that in these
alternating path every edge would trail
was probably at least 1/2 that's roughly
what happens in okay
[Applause]
maximal matching you mean no but like
you can isolate edges I mean the
matching says new grows but those are
not gonna help yeah so okay so agreed
there might be other reasonable in your
large market assumptions there I think
one nice thing about this result is I
mean we didn't prove a theorem but if
you have a reasonably large market
assumption and the true reduction there
you can just plug in our random offering
mechanism in the second phase we're not
using too much properties about you know
how you do tree reduction we're only
using the fact that you're actually
trading on the first best edges and
we're into tree reduction that's
basically what you do you can prove some
sort of more modular result we didn't
say the result that way but I think if
you have other types of large market
assumptions you can basically take the
second part and you know still get
Thanks
[Applause]